[Music]
question party is very simple
a bunch of viewers tweeted questions at
me and tarek and we're going to answer
some of them right now
you ready i'm ready april seminole asked
what's the best concert you've been to
in your life so far
okay so
i'm on a date with some dude we are
seeing a
um a uh
a stevie wonder concert okay so i'm on a
date with some guy
we are watching stevie wonder this is in
amsterdam
i'm so close to stevie wonder we're like
right up front and i'm
melting i'm so excited so like as i'm
watching stevie wonder
he has you know a pretty hot
backup singer so i'm like watching
stevie wonder and enjoying him
and i'm like gosh that guy's hot okay
anyway all right
watching stevie wonder and then the
backup singer
this is true starts looking at me like
and i'm like
me and hot backup singer are making eyes
at each other
and then he i swear to god
goes like this he's he's here stevie
wonder is here
he is looking at me look at me he goes
like this
you know one thing about me and that is
i like stevie wonder you dumb
i couldn't believe he did that what he
truly
was could reach out and touch stevie
wonder what
yeah yeah he did i won
that's the dumbest funniest bit
can you believe this guy oh this guy
right am i right everybody oh hey sharia
[ __ ]
seal delivered to the wrong address
you're at a concert for the that is the
person everyone came to see
you guys that's all the time we have for
question party this was great
let's do it again soon eat the food that
you want
eat the food i would not eat that
by the way
[Music]
you